episodes five and six aired last night
the last
dance espn's documentary on the chicago
bulls jason harris done a great job as
the director
uh seven and eight will air next sunday
may 10th starting
at nine eastern jason let me start with
the music
the choice of music that you have in
trying to match the period there
uh give me the detail that went into
that
um it's the most important aspect of it
to me anytime we do a project
um the first thing i start with is the
music and you know i i walk around my
neighborhood in new york and listen to
songs that we may use that we may not
use but something that gets me in the
mood of what that music
uh or what the doc is going to sound
like how the story is going to feel and
the texture of the entire documentary is
the music
this was a really great opportunity
because this doc
is based in 80s and 90s nostalgia and
my greatest musical love is old school
hip-hop so i could not wait to sink my
teeth into um
matching up songs to each era that we're
covering in each episode so it was a
field day we had an
incredible team of um music clearance
people
hip hop is old school hip-hop is the
hardest thing to clear because there's
so many samples and
so many of them went unchecked back in
the day like no one was keeping track of
those before sampling laws came into
effect
but uh rudy chung and the guys that hit
the ground running did an incredible job
with this so i was lucky to have them
what kind of music fan is jordan or was
jordan back then
i think he's more r b i don't think that
he's the kind of guy who would listen to
i'm bad ella cool j before a game he
he famously said that he listens to um
giving you the best that i've got
anita baker before games and it just
wouldn't
it's it's just another incredible thing
about him uh
big or small but it wouldn't have fit
the tone that that i was trying to
to match uh in the doc so we decided to
go with our own taste rather than
michael's
uh when you have the barack obama
comment you have the political topic
where you know mike says you know
republicans by nikes as well then you
have president obama
his comment on being disappointed in
mike did did jordan know
what obama was going to say in the
documentary
uh he didn't know what president obama
was going to say but he saw that episode
i mean he saw
i was surprised this goes back to you
know um
people saying that michael has creative
control or
[Music]
um he could have taken out anything that
that we did
um he had the power to do so and he
never wielded that power he
that that sound bite that's in there
where the guy compares him to muhammad
ali and says michael will never be like
ali
not only did michael want to keep that
in he wanted to answer to that because
he saw a rough cut
of episode 5 before we did that
interview when he's in the black shirt
the black shirt interview is from
december of last year
so that's why you see him speaking on
that in the blue shirt which was two
years ago
and then he saw the cut and said i leave
it in and i want to speak to that as
well
the ali stuff so it was it was
interactive with him throughout
he doesn't apologize for anything no
he doesn't um and
you know i was talking with my
girlfriend last night watching this it
it's a refreshing i think it's part of
the refreshing part of this doc is that
no one seems to horace grant says no i
was not the guy who
who leaked that stuff to sam smith
isaiah says that's the way that people
did it back then they walked off
michael says if you want someone to
stand behind the podium and further your
agenda
you're probably following the wrong guy
follow somebody else i love the fact
that these guys stand by what they did
decades ago uh and it's they're not
they're not being
indignant they just believe in what they
say
what's jordan didn't take out anything
i'm sorry jordan didn't take out
anything oh he did
not no um and when you see the episodes
next week
you'll be surprised maybe he skipped
episode seven i'm not sure but i can't
believe that
he didn't wait well what what did he
that you have the steve kerr fight
but what what is tasty that he should
have maybe had and
edited is only a story that's told and
he was eager to tell that and steve was
too but
the the the the footage this treasure
trove of footage that we have from the
nba
what we tackle in episode seven and
eight next week is is what it was like
to play with michael
and then what it was like to play
against him and seven and eight
respectively
and the with michael stuff man i don't
know if you would want to practice with
michael jordan it'd be fun to watch i
don't know if it'd be fun to
to interact with him during that because
he is hard he wanted to make those
practices harder than any game could
possibly be and in the east back in the
90s
that meant making it as rough and as as
mentally grueling
as possible and there's things in there
there's language in there that i'm
shocked that espn let us keep in and
there's behavior in there that i'm
shocked that michael let us keep in but
we were lucky enough that we had great
partners in both
i remember when i would be at the nba
finals and have a chance to talk to judd
bushler
or steve kerr and they would always talk
about
you know how intense they always said
you're seeing it from the outside we see
it from the inside
it's not as enjoyable on the inside on
the outside it looks like you're playing
with jordan and we're winning
championships
it was really tough and if you got the
look they
they always talked about you never
wanted the look from jordan because if
you got the look you weren't getting the
ball
like that intensity that they had every
single practice
you know that it goes back to when mike
decided to take a couple years off
i think mike got so into this and had to
be so much to so many things and so many
people
i don't know if he could have continued
to do what he was doing
and i think he actually needed a break
we see coaches do this
yeah burnout i think mike had burnout
after watching all of this jace i think
he had burnout
did he address that he did and we
address it more because he actually
he leaves for baseball and you'll see
all his baseball experience is covered
in episode seven and episode eight
is his comeback from baseball um it
absolutely was burnout
and uh you know he he wanted to do this
as recently as 92 from 93 but as far
back if you look at
there's a roy firestone interview from
1984
on up close on espn and michael says to
firestone
when he's about to leave unc uh for the
draft
he says that he's gonna leave pro
basketball at 30 and become a golfer
he always had this in his mind that he
was going to do this
dominate for a while then leave and go
do something else just how his mind
works i'm sure he's sitting at home in
quarantine right now wondering what else
he can beat
once this thing gets lifted and he can
go out and interact with the rest of the
world
so he was absolutely burnt out and then
it was it was
greatly compounded by the death of his
dad he was grieving
and he needed a reset um so we addressed
some of the reasons that people say
he he left this this uh suspension
conspiracy theory
we address all that with david stern
with michael and others
but the guy was burnt out he was done he
he was he was done
uh physically he was done mentally he
was done spiritually and he needed to go
somewhere else
he's jason hare he's the director of
espn's the last dance
you've got episodes uh five and six that
aired last night seven and eight will
air next sunday may 10th
starting at nine eastern what was the
toughest question you asked him
throughout all of this
it was hard to discuss his dad um
because you know one of our goals in
this thing was to present these guys as
human beings
not as icons not as statues but as human
beings and when you're talking to
someone about losing their their parent
no matter what the circumstances
it's a tough thing to bring up and when
you're talking to someone about their
father being murdered
it's extremely tough to bring up and
then you have to ask the question
of of how do you respond to these rumors
that you were somehow responsible for
his death
it's it's just kind of a it's a it's a
stew of difficult topics to bring up all
in one subject and all in one time
period
so um i gave him a heads up before the
interview that that
this is going to be one of the ones
where we go deep on that kind of stuff
and just prepare for that
and i told them from the outset that
there's going to be difficult questions
that i ask you you can choose to answer
them however you please
i have to ask them and he respected that
did you ever get the look from him like
he was disappointed in you
mad i don't think so i mean
i i got the look like that's a dumb
question or i got the look like
he he's he's i don't know if you can say
this on your air but he's a ball buster
definitely and part of that is fun you
know that you know
a lot more than i have you know the the
final
final interview that we did um we
finished the interview and i said is
there anything else that you want to add
to this and he
made some sort of joke like no i think
we have it covered in eight hours of
talking and then i said all right 10
seconds of room tone
and we have to do that for editing
purposes so everyone in the room has to
be quiet and we just have to record the
sound of the room
quietly for 10 seconds i said all right
10 seconds go
and i have to count to 10 in my head and
then i call it and the interview is
wrapped
so i called all right room tone 10
seconds
i was quiet counted to 10 and said all
right thanks we're done he said that was
13.
[Laughter]
who said no to an interview
there were some um
you know my standard answer so far has
been that we we got every person we
wanted to tell
a story from uh all the stories we
wanted to tell we got the right person
to tell the story um there were people
who said no i'd rather not share that
who was reluctant
uh stockton was reluctant um
because you know i finally got him on
the phone we interviewed john stockton
on march 10th
um this march 10th yeah so
that was tuesday march 10th we
interviewed him in spokane it was so it
was so deep into this kovid crisis that
that um we decided i shouldn't fly to
spokane because we were afraid
that flights would get grounded
indefinitely so we had someone out there
um a stringer from seattle drove in and
did that interview
he was reluctant because i finally got
him on the phone after like two years of
chasing him
in january or february and he said i
don't want to be part of a michael
jordan puff piece
and i said i can assure you that this is
not a puff piece and i explained to him
who else was participating and that he
was the
106th interview in the process and and
what we were covering
um and then guys like bj armstrong were
reluctant
out of out of deference to michael
because they're protecting michael and
they wanted to know
you know who these people are who are
telling this story is michael cool with
it there were plenty of people who
you know it's not easy to get people to
sit down and talk about michael because
he cast such a large shadow over
people's
lives still so they want to know all
sorts of details about all right who is
this
telling the story um what have they done
before
what kind of story is this gonna be so
we had a lot of reluctance but
um very few i mean we had 106 interviews
and we cast a really wide net and maybe
two or three people said they'd rather
not be a part of it but the fact that
stockton says i don't want to be part of
a puff piece
how did you react to that i loved it um
i've never heard john stockton's voice
never heard it he's so reticent i mean
he he could have sounded
like scottie pippen he could have
sounded like my mom like i had no idea
what he was gonna sound like
but i respected him more for saying no
it's not it's not that i don't want to
do it it's just that i don't feel like
gushing about michael jordan for a half
hour and you guys putting it
he's still it still stings
those losses oh reggie miller was on a
couple of weeks ago jace
i mean reggie's another guy reggie's
another guy man
and we tried and tried and tried it and
we were getting official nose from
reggie
um and gail degasino who's his manager i
had to reach out to her personally and
assure her like we were doing this the
right way
we were getting no's from him and then i
was listening to him called games
and he was saying you know i haven't
gotten a call yet i'm hoping to be a
part of this thing and i was like
reggie we're dying for you to be a part
of this but it still stings with these
guys
um larry bird is is um legendarily
larry legend no pun intended legendarily
uh reluctant to speak about anything he
just doesn't like doing these interviews
um
but it's like i said before that when
when michael calls people pick up on the
first ring
so magic said i don't know if this
happened but magic told me that
when he did it he called larry and said
you have to do it because i did
it's this it's this incredible you know
mount rushmore of guys who who have this
this
kind of pact that they all are going to
tell each other stories it's really cool
to
to observe what was your reaction when
the uh you know
ken burns who does documentaries for a
living
said that this really wasn't a
documentary the last stance how did you
react to that
uh ken burns is one of my idols
he's got an extraordinary body of work
and and he's one of the reasons why i
wanted to
to do what would i do now so um
i was a little disappointed that he
hadn't seen it yet and he seemed to be
casting judgment um
but he called me the other day um and
couldn't have been more gracious and
couldn't have been more classy
and said that he apologized not for what
he said but for the fact that it was
taken out of context and that he deals
in a pbs
world where anyone who has a remote
connection to the subject is
automatically
uh forbidden to be a part of the process
and so for for michael to be a partner
in this and for him to be watching rough
cuts he said that that's just something
that that would not happen
in in my world um so
it was really you know it was incredible
to actually get a phone call from that
guy because i've looked up to him
forever
uh also i would say that i i'm not
you know what we do is journalistic but
i wouldn't call myself a journalist i
i am in the business of storytelling
and we use a visual medium to tell these
stories and when someone like michael
jordan grants you the access and the
permission to tell his story
you'd be a fool not to take it and i'm
proud to say and michael should be proud
to say that there was never
one frame of this documentary that he
that he exercised any censorship over
so ken is in his business he does a
great job at it
um he's a legend he's in any kind of
filmmaking hall of fame that you could
think of
and i'm trying to do my job as well we
have 10 episodes
can you see maybe an 11th episode there
jason
like leftovers there's a lot of
leftovers
there were 500 hours of footage that
season and and we stopped telling our
story in 1998.
what if espn said give us an 11th
just leftovers outtakes um
i would have to take a nap and
[Laughter]
decide after i got a good sleep are you
done with nine and ten
are they we're not they're not are you
done with seven and eight
yes again mine is done seven eight nine
are done
ten uh i'm waiting i'm i'm pacing
outside the delivery room right now
they're supposed to give episode 10 um
the final audio mix and the final color
correction any day now
i watch that i give my notes they
incorporate my notes i watch it a final
time and then that's that so i think
if we talk again i think that uh when we
talk again it'll be
it'll be done i'll a plume of white
smoke will come out of a
high rise in tribeca you'll see we'll
have our next pope
um i i think there's gonna be it feels
like
there there's gonna be an eleventh
episode am i crazy in saying that has
that been discussed
it has not been discussed okay uh i just
came up with it we discussed it so
you can say it's in in discussion you've
had discussions
we had a discussion here jason we it's
been it's been discussed that there will
be an election
with any partners who would who would
greenlight it and i i love seeing kobe
you know you don't realize how impactful
those words are
until obviously with what happened but
i i thought it was just such a mature
way to approach this
jordan legacy of i'm not there with him
he's the reason why i am where i am i i
those
it was i mean it hit hard for me it hit
hard uh i haven't seen these episodes in
a long time
because we signed off on these
pre-covered and it's been such a
uh race to the finish line um
you know after he passed away it was
always striking in the edit room to see
him come up
i will never wrap my head around it i
don't think any of us will it doesn't
make sense that someone who who seemed
that
vibrant and vital and immortal frankly
uh could be gone so
it's you know it's not the most
articulate way to say
man but it is so sad to watch that last
night was so sad it's so poignant
because of michael's speech too at the
at the memorial
you know that from both sides that's
confirmed this is not just athlete bs
and yeah he's my big brother he really
felt
that way about him and michael really
felt that way about kobe it was such a
special relationship there's such
kindred spirits
um and to say it hit home is you know an
understatement
go take a nap jason thanks hey
well done so far and uh we'll look
forward to that 11th episode you heard
it here first on the dan patrick show
[Laughter]
thank you jace all right man that's uh
jason hare
he's the director of espn's the last
dance